Her low freak bitches is huge.
Where I'll be like a thing going on now
is a lot of people are building like a
dorms.
Yeah.
Their capstone,
which makes a lot of sense.
So many guys are bouncing around to sure.
You know,
they come from out of town to go train
in and a great Jackson's is building one
like that.
And Greg,
Jack Cowboy said he
has a bad motherfucker.
Rans Cowboy.
Cowboy look against Cotto holy
fucking screaming at the TV.
He looked fucking awesome.
Sensational.
And one 70,
he looks goddamn sensational.
I mean that it's like everything
came together at one 70.
[inaudible] and [inaudible] is a beast,
man.
Nope.
Nobody's ever worked Coty over the way.
Cowboy did.
And he's he coattails far father
like two oh five before too,
right?
Yeah.
Because the first is what
he was saying that uh,
at one 70,
the guy who was also like
a one 55 are coming up,
but it was like a new weight.
Right?
Hmm.
Who's this first?
Oh,
cowboys.
Yeah.
Was a big dude.
That was that other cowboy dude.
Yeah.
Um,
but that guy is big.
He's a big fella.
He was bigger than cowboy boots cowboy.
I caught him in the triangle,
but he just looked great.
But like Kofi with a body like
one 85 and then he started,
his first fight was at two oh
five he dropped Tito Ortiz.
This is way back in the day.
It's when Tito was a light
heavyweight champ I believe.
And I think Tito was
either champ or in the,
I mean it was,
Tito was in his prime and he lost to
Tito at light heavyweight and then went
down to one 85 fought Anderson Silva.
He was doing very well,
very smart fight.
He fought a very smart fight against
Anderson where he was like making Anderson
lead in Anderson's really counter guy and
he was just sort of laying it back and
Anderson didn't like it and he doesn't,
the Anderson does not like it when he
had like a weird knee popped or something
and he blew out.
Yeah,
you're like lifted his leg up to throw
a kick and his knee just buckled and
shaved in on him.
Shit happen sometimes.
Like,
Oh yeah,
weird freak shit.
Like that happens a lot in this sport.
Well sure.
And there's also like injuries that you
get like the second and third round that
you don't even know what you mean.
You felt your knee pop,
you're not exactly sure what it is and
you're still standing on and everything
seems fine and then you throw
a kick and it just gives out.
There's that,
you know?
But the point is Coty is a stud.
He said,
tough fucking guy and to have cowboy work,
I'm like that.
I was like,
whew,
Ninja.
It looked fucking Aussie
like terminator that night.
Like he looks like,
yeah,
awesome.
It looked like a world
fucking happy for me.
Legit world champion.
Yup.
Yeah.
I hope he can keep that together.
I really do.
I think one 70 I think these guys that
are fucking depleting themselves so badly
to cut weight,
I think that's going to
be a thing of the past.
I really do.
I think people got to realize like,
this is not the benefit that you get
in that is it's negligible cowboys.
Wayne,
like one 76 somewhere around that and
he's cutting just a little bit of weight
and making one 70 easy.
Yeah.
I think he was like four or five
pounds off when he came there.
Zero.
We sparked a couple of weeks before the
fight and he was like 14 days out and he
was like five pounds.
Like you'd go out to eat,
we're eating whatever.
Well,
that's nice shit.
Drinking a beer.
He's so fucking ridiculous with that.
He drinks beer up until
the day of the weigh ins.
Yeah,
that can't be good right now.
Why?
Well,
a little bit of beer is probably okay.
Okay.